YouTubeを見てくださってる皆さん
、新年あけましておめでとうございます。
え、本当にまた新しい2026年
キックオフということですね。え、昨年は
ありがとうございました。本当に多くの方
にですね、ご支援いただきまして本当に
素晴らしい1年を私も送ることができまし
た。え、今年も頑張ります。是非
YouTube応援よろしくお願いします
。ます。今年も良い年にしましょう。
自分の経営目的は何なのか。誰のために、
何のために、なぜあなたは経しているのか
。部合って利己的な人間がさらに履行的に
なっちゃうわけよ。競争ではなく、共に
作る競争負荷をかけないと成長はしないん
ですよ。でも負荷はかけるもんじゃなくて
自らが選択してくものなんですよ。
[音楽]青木サトの人生警察学100回
聞いたら豊かになる話。
今日の質問はこの半年社員の離職が続き同揺しています。
お、
最初は偶然かと思いましたが、連鎖が止まらず、現場は人手出手不足で疲弊気味です。会社が急画拡大する中で数字ばかり追ってしまい、組織の変化や小さな不満を見落としていたのではないかと自の念に駆られています。
うん。
急な離職が続く際、経営者はまず何を見ぼすべきでしょうかというご質問です。
欲求が満たされてない。それが事実です。
働く人の欲求が満たされていない。この
会社にいても自分は幸せになれない。この
会社にいても自分は自己実現できない。
幸せじゃないんだよね。要は。っていう
ことは、ま、シンプルですよ。何事でも
人々からして欲しいと望む通りのことを他
の人々にもそのようにしなさいとバイブル
にはマタで7章12節に答えがあるので
社員の立場に身を置いて考えたらいいです
。やめてった人はしょうがない。でも今
残ってる人たちは少なくとも会社に愛者
精神を持ち社長のことを思っている人そう
いう人が残ってるんですよ。こういう人を
失わないためにもここで襟りを正すって
ことですね。そして自分の目的は何なのか
。もう1回誰のために?何のために?なぜ
あなたは敬しているのか?そのことを自分
の目的が働く人から見て魅力的かどうか。
だから自分は金持ちになりたい。自分は
成功したい。そのために社員をこ期使う。
例えばね、この方がコ期使って
るっていうわけじゃないよ。こういう悩み
を持ってること自体ものすごいまともな
経営者だとは僕は信じてるけれども、だ
けどその自分の願望と他の人の願望がその
ぶつかってる状態、人間っていうのは本来
利己的なき生き物なんですよ。それはどう
いう意味かと悪いことじゃないんです。
自分の遺伝子を満たさないと命を守ろうと
してるわけだから命イコール時間じゃない
時の時を充実させたいとそれは当たり前の
話だよね。っていうことはどの会社にい
たら自分の欲求は満たされるのか誰と仕事
をしたら自分の欲求は満たされるのか人間
っては利己的なんだよ。その利己的な人間
の存在を悪いものと捉えずにそれを逆に
相手が利己的なんだから相手の望みを
叶えることを自分の望みとすればいいん
ですよ。僕はね自分も含めて人間は利己的
であるとそういう風に作られているんだと
。仏教的に言うと豪が深いってことかな。
うん。キリスト教的に言うと罪深い存在だ
。そういう自分なんだけれども、じゃあ
どうしたらいいかと言うと、やっぱり利己
ではなくリタ、リタの心を持てるように
そういう情報教育を1つしっかりとする
ことともう1つはこれ本当大事。経営者は
社員を物資共に豊かにしてあげることを
経営の目的にするんです。私がなんでこれ
だけ豊かになったかって言うと本当に明解
なん。お客様に対しては誠実でありたいの
でお客様にベストの商品やベストの
サービスを提供したいと思っているので
それを組織的に提供していきたいのでA
ランク人材の採用と今いる人材をAランク
人材に育てることに対して妥協なく
取り組んだってことだよね。でもAランク
人材はやめないのよ。
だからその誰がやめるかなんだよね。
やめることで一気一しちゃいけない。ただ
Aランク人材がやめてBランクとCランク
ばっかり残ってるとBランクもやめちゃっ
たとCランクしかいないとなったらもう
この会社は潰れます。だからどこも行く
とこのない人間が残ってるってこと。そう
じゃなくてAランク人材というのは明確な
目的目標を持ち自らの意思で自分の願望を
実現してける人間と定義していいわけだ
からその願望を実現できる人事効果制度や
仕組みを整えてあげて会社で自己実現の
舞台を与えてあげてそこで自己実現した時
には十分な精神的経済的報酬で報
それを目的に慶用していくと相手から見
たらいきなり魅力的な会社になるんですよ
。で、それで多くの人は部合っていう発想
になるんだけど部合って利己的な人間が
さらに利己的になっちゃうわけよ。だから
チームでみんなで達成した時にその果実を
フェアに分かちゃおうねっていう仕組みの
方が理的になるんですよ。
ではなく共に作る競争会社の仕組みって
チャレンジングなものにしてでそれをお客
様への貢献目標としてお客様にたくさんの
貢献をしようよと一緒にで貢献をして与え
られた果実であるま税引き語利益をシェア
する会社はその株主も去ることながら本当
に社員の自己実現の舞台でもあるだ。ここ
で会社の経営者がかの肺まで俺のもの
みたいな意識を持つのか共同体として一緒
にいい組織を作っていこうと考えるのかの
この考え方の差ってものすごく重要なん
ですよ。だから僕はやっぱり社員と共に
理想を追求してきた経営なので僕にとって
は社員の望みを叶えることを自分の望みと
する。もって言うとプライベートでは家族
の望みを叶えることを自分の望みとする。
社会では社会の望みを叶えることを自分の
望みとする。自分の望みが対象となる対員
、対客。それはお取りき先もそうだし、
株主もそうだし、協力会社
社会全部そういういわゆる、ま、ステーク
ホルダーダーていう表現がいいのかどうか
分からないけど、ま、うちはプライベート
カンパニーだけれども、でも少なくとも
そういうステークホルダー経営的な経営が
できている。だから相手の望みを叶える
ことを自分の望みとするということが離職
を止めるマスターキーなんじゃないの。だ
からまともな経営して会社が成長しない方
がおかしいわけで、だけど僕は社員に絶対
負荷をかけすぎないようにしてます。負荷
をかけないと成長はしないんですよ。でも
負荷はかけるもんじゃなくて自らが選択し
てくものなんですよ。自分から仕事は取り
に行かなきゃだめなんですよ。そういう
やっぱり経営者が、ま、経営能力というか
実学、経営の実学を学ばないとこの問題は
解決しないと思います。うん。今のね、
あの質問の中にね、申し訳ないけどね、
フォミを感じる。うん。やっぱり社員から
見てね、コ気使われる感じてんじゃないの
かな。うん。すごくね、だから本当うちの
研修受けてる人の中にもいるもん。誹の
拡大走って上場上場目指して管理部門の
人間がものす負荷かかって本当にこう管理
部長がよくやめるような会社ってろな会社
じゃないんですよ。やっぱりね最適目標
勾配ってあるんですよ。負荷かけすぎると
怪我するよ。車でもそうだよね。スピード
を出しすぎるとクラッシュを起こすじゃん
。やっぱり1回クラッシュを起こしちゃっ
たらレースからね、もう退上しなきゃいけ
ないわけじゃん。やっぱりそのギリギリの
ところ狙うんだけど、やっぱりそこが運転
技術なんだよ。だ、僕はそのギリギリの
ところだ。今年は110%でいいよって
ブレーキ踏んでても115%行っちゃっ
たり。俺110%でいいよ。いいよって
言ってんの。125%とかさ。いや、本当
にそうなんだよ。これはもう逆に困ってん
ですよ。なぜかて言うと現場が負荷すぎて
ないかなってパトロールしてんだから
大丈夫かといい状態かって逆に心配してん
のよ俺。ちゃんと休み取れてるかとか
ちゃんと家族旅行を計画に入れようとか。
逆だもんね。俺1回も働けって言ったこと
ないんだから。愛を土台にした経していく
とうまくいくんですよ。あのね、チック
フィレっていうね、アメリカのファースト
フーズの会社があるの。これマクドナルド
と同じのハンバーガーのような会社ですよ
ね。ものすごい公衆収益ですよ。日曜日
休みなんだから。ファーストフーズで
日曜日休みなんて考えられないでしょ、
普通は。だけどいい人が働きたいのよ。
なぜクリスチャン日曜日休みたいもん。
いい人材いっぱい集まってきて。で、人で
困らないから人材で困らないし、いい人材
はクオリティの高い仕事するから。なん
だろう。だからすごいなと思うな。
オーナー経営者クリスチャンじゃないと
FCさせないとかさ。そうなんだよ。だ
からまともな人と仕事をしてるからまとも
な系ができてるからずっと公収益だよね。
いや、本当に。だからクオリティを追求し
ていくことこそがま、僕は経営の親髄だと
思ってるんでだ。うちの企業理念は上の
追求と我が者は選択の元にした品質の人材
教育を通して顧客の成果の想像に貢献し、
全社員の物進両面の幸福の追求と社会の
平和と反栄に起与する。これを目的に
240人全員でこれに向かってるんですよ
。だから離職はプライベートな理由があっ
てね、離職する人いるけどでもうちの社員
離職してもあのLINEになんか登録して
ね、自分の代わりにやめますって言って
もらうような社員なんか誰1人いない。
必ずどんな忙しくても社長すいませんけど
お忙しいのは分かってるけれどもちょっと
ご挨拶をしたいんですってみんなやめる時
も立つ取りあと煮干さずで感謝を伝えて
くれて離職してくよね。僕もその時間は最
優先するよね。
本当はね、これもう1回今日のこの番組ね
、最初からもう1回見直してもらいたい。
全部エッセンスです。でもあえてじゃ言い
ましょう。相手の立場に立って答えを出し
なさいってことです。何事でも人々からし
て欲しいと望む通りのことを他の人々にも
そのようにせよこの人々を社員に置き換え
てください。何事でも社員からして欲しい
と望む通りのことを社員にもそのように
せよじゃんじゃん。以上って感じです。
よろしいでしょうか?じゃあコメント欄に
ね、ちょっと気合いが入りすぎましたけど
どうぞコメントよろしくお願いします。
そしてえ是非ねチャンネル登録まだであれ
ばお願いします。一緒に、え、この番組
育てていきたいと思います。よろしくお
願いします。
ま、僕はともかくできる限りのことしたい
と思いますね。今年1年振り返っても
新しく社員のためにまず東京勤務の子には
社員の手当てね、別っこに出したよな。
地方と日本あの東京の違いは東京は家賃が
高い。同じ新卒の子でも33万の中で東京
配属なったら家賃が高いのでその負担が
大きい。よし、じゃあ東京勤務の子には
出してあげよう。33万出してんだから
自分じゃないかって言う人いるけれど違う
。フェアね。そしてさらにはあの食事接近
で一生懸命頑張ってる人材がい
るっていうのを聞いた。して、え、うちの
マネージャーもう2人結婚して2人とも
マネージャーになってで、よく聞いたら
ベビーシッターさん雇って一生懸命頑張っ
てるって聞いた。ベビーシッターの費用が
めちゃ高いって聞いた。よし、じゃあ食事
接近で手当て別っこに出してやろうと。で
、負担にしてやろうと。ま、それから、ま
、いろんな手当てを増やしたよね、今年。
もっと増やしたいと思ってます。いや、
本当。だからなんだろう。今例えば南町に
ね、あのアーチュメントハウスを立てよう
としてるけど、その今あるログハウスも
川口が今の保用場だけど、去南町にもあの
ログハウスを社員のためのう、そういうね
、保容所にしようと今考えていたり、ま、
いろんなこと考えてるけど僕は社員と共に
セルフカウンセリングの守護私は何を求め
ているのか私にとって1番大切なものは
何か私が本当に求めているものそのために
今何をしているのか。その行動は私が
求めるものを手にね入れるために効果的
もっと良い方法が出し考え実行してみよう
。その私はの守護をやっぱり社員とその
家族は何を求めているのか。社員とその
家族にとって1番大切なものは何か社員と
その家族が本当に求めてるもの。それは
当然健康であって欲しいと。自分が愛する
お父さん、お母さんの健康を望んでる
だろうと。だからやっぱり負荷をかけすぎ
ないようにしよう。いや、独身の子は親御
さんから預かってるわけじゃん。なら親御
さんから見たらやっぱり子供の幸せを願っ
てるわけなんで、それはちゃんと労働環境
を整えいいオフィス環境で働けるようにし
てあげようとか投資しようとか結果的に
情けは人のためならずって言葉はあるけど
相手のためと思ってやったことが結果的に
自分に回り回ってきて祝福を受けてるん
ですよ。それが経常利益30億なんですよ
。本当にうちで学ぶ経営者再行して欲しい
んですよ。何度も何度も再受行しないと
この守護がどうしても私はの方が先行し
ちゃうの。私は何を求めてるのか?金儲け
。私にとって1番大事なのは金儲け。私が
本当に求めた金儲け。この金儲けと何の
ために金儲設儲けしたいのっていう時に
社員を幸せにするためにお客様にもっと
貢献するために社会にもっと納税するため
にとそのためのにもっと健全な利益を出し
たいなら
社員と1つになるわけよ。だってその分
社員も頑張ったら自分が報われるわけだ
から。だそれが結論だよ。としたら離食0
はとは言わない。あの、なぜなら守られた
水は腐るので。あ、これ絶対よくね、離職
ゼロをね、誇る人いるんだけど大丈夫って
思ってるよ。逆なんだよ、俺。大丈夫って
よ。本当にだ。逆になんと変な人はやめた
方がいいんだから。だから採用ミスをした
時には自分から手は離さないけどその文化
についていけなければね愛は青流にしか
済まないんだからナズはまね沼に住むんだ
から沼の環境じゃないとしたら愛は青流に
しか済まないんだから青流っていうのは
やっぱり顧客に対する誠実さを貫くという
意味ではクオリティを妥協なく要求し
なきゃダめなんですよ。経営者はそれが辛
いって言ったら努力が足りないわけじゃん
。そしたらその報われる人間はどんどん
小心昇格をして怠け物は小心昇格ができ
ない。それはやっぱり怠けてる人は離職し
てくかもしれないよね。でも常に毎年優秀
な人材を入れ続けていったら会社は発展
するんじゃないですか。
決して負けない経営だ。まず経営者自身が
お金よりも仕事の内容そのものに惚れ込ん
でるかどうかなです。
[音楽]